a astute Observer of human behavior now
right like I've I've taken
I've taken the red pill I've spent time
in the Nano swamp I've read the Evo
psych I've hung out with a psychologist
I've done you know the observational
human behavior and it seems like from
that perspective there's a lot of women
that I look at out there that are
working doing jobs that are
in a job to me is an acronym for just
over broke because that's what they're
generally living they're living paycheck
to paycheck they're not wealthy they're
not they don't have Fu money they're not
maneuverable they don't have the ability
to
take off six months they haven't got
funds saved up they just live in
paycheck to paycheck and they don't have
a look of
Joy on their face there's an emptiness
doing
you know serving a guy in a corporation
and lining his pocket with gold and I
wonder why they aren't doing something
in a home and it's not so much that I
wonder it's almost like I know at this
point because it seems like Society
culture men and women you know
collectively have been sold a version of
that video there that you know that 16
second video where it's like don't get
married because you're gonna have to do
all of these things and it's like
slavery right but paying taxes is
slavery sitting in traffic going to work
as slavery uh like do doing things to
contribute to another guy's business
that lines his pocket with gold where he
pays you you know the bare minimum is
slavery like everything that we do
you know comes at a compromise it comes
at a concession and I wonder if culture
I wonder if women are happy do you guys
see women as happy today doing
you know doing the corporate gigs you
know climbing the corporate ladder you
know getting their little accolades and
certificates with little letters after
their name to frame and mahogany put on
the wall sort of thing like do you see
happiness and joy in women's faces
I think there's a mask a mask of
happiness but I think if you looked it
down and I'm not saying that's
necessarily the case for every single
person right but I think probably a lot
of the women in those scenarios
um deep down aren't as happy as they
portrayed themselves to be
achievements like that
I don't know I mean you dedicate all
your time it just depends on what you
consider to be an achievement for
yourself I know my I personally wouldn't
be happy in a situation like that oh
well I've teached their own I suppose
but yeah if I you know I don't have them
hanging up in this room they're actually
my parents have them displayed at their
house like my you know my degrees are in
the hallway as soon as you walk into my
parents house
um and like any time I've had any kind
of accomplishment like
I was happy obviously because that's
something to celebrate and nobody can
take that away from me I don't care if I
if I go to your Instagram right now ice
ice chill will you have those sorry ice
I see chill will you have those
accomplishments will you have those
degrees proudly displayed there actually
not because I had to really do my
Instagram account not that long ago
because I uh had a similar situation to
Nicole okay
um but no and I I usually I use social
media more for streaming now if you're
so if your degrees are something that
you're proud of those achievements why
don't you share those with the world on
Instagram why do you share
um I share my other my real achievement
stuff that I want people to know about
goes on my Facebook it does not go on
Instagram because I
none of my family really has Instagram
sure I have friends on Instagram but
like
can I share your Instagram just to sort
of like frame this sure is that cool so
uh ice okay yeah so this is the right
one here
so um it says find me on Twitch YouTube
and Tick Tock so you're a twitch
streamer
um but you're a therapist and your
Instagram is uh basically check me out
um I don't see your degree I don't see
the pride in your degree I see more of
um
like
going back to a place where
women typically and traditionally are
which has Beauty objects to men like
you're selling your beauty
to men in that fashion but your degrees
that you have on your parents walls
don't matter they're not shown here
we've got not on Instagram no because I
don't use Instagram for that I use my
Facebook for more personal things okay
but if those are achievements why aren't
you sharing that though like that's what
I don't understand
because it doesn't matter for my
Instagram because that's not the kind of
content that I post on there do you
think that women are Beauty objects or
do you think that there's success
objects
um both honestly
if you have a beautiful successful woman
and that's that's your wife or that's
your girlfriend like she's 10 times
better than everybody else if she's got
both
okay it's better you know if you have a
pretty face that sits at home like yeah
she's probably great she takes care of
you she loves you but can can the um Can
the chat let us know you know live chat
that's watching anyway like our women
Beauty objects are they success objects
to you or would you prefer a woman to be
a beauty object and a success objects
let us know from that regard but
um yeah like I'm just curious about that
because uh I had no idea that you had a
degree I had no idea that you were
um in uh you know two degrees that
you're in therapy because if I look at
your social media if I look at your
Instagram page
um you look like an Instagram model like
one of those uh you know girls that are
selling like uh energy drinks or fat
burning to use or something like that
nope you don't have any sponsors
promoting my twitch nope so what do you
do on Twitch like what sort of streaming
do you do is it like gaming or something
or yep I'm a big gamer I got a little
Zelda mask behind me I got my gaming set
up on the opposite side of this okay
ring light here I'm super nerd I'm into
anime I got my favorite coffee cup here
yeah there's so many rabbit holes I can
go down on this one Loft do you wanna
you wanna hop in
no I mean look like it's we can go at a
bunch of different I mean video games
always were for like teenage boys and
like nerds growing up and now it's
become like it's huge and it's I mean
there's so many more women playing video
games now and doing it
on I've been playing video games since
like 1995 with the Game Boy Color right
I mean in general though like the the
amount of women that are in the gamer
space now like didn't exist 15 years ago
you know when hey I was playing Halo 2
when I was 13 and 14 like that wasn't a
thing we if you ran into a girl player
it was like Halley's comment it came
around once every 75 years yeah even
then you couldn't be convinced that she
was the actual one playing it was like
oh she's probably like with her
boyfriend she's just whatever it is or
that yeah
but I think the point we're trying to
get to though is you know
most men generally are not
when they're looking for a woman to date
the amount of degrees how smart she is
her IQ whether she's got a PhD or
whether she's got a Bachelor's or high
school diploma no matter how much
doesn't matter she's making twenty
thousand dollars a year or a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars a year
that's generally not what guys care
about when they go disagree data woman
so why do you what do you disagree with
the amount of people
men even okay I guess the the girls that
have told me that that told me how much
like hotter or sexier it was that they
that I had a master's degree or even
that I am just able to articulate
you know a simple simple communication
and it's not just oh my God you know
like I disagree with that people find it
more attractive guys
because you don't have a masters doesn't
mean you're just like oh my God and
can't hold a conversation no I know I
don't have a masters and I don't
consider myself
dumb and unable to hold a conversation
you know and I I didn't say that I don't
want to say talking in like extremes
like it's either you have a masters or
you're like oh my God I can't hold a
conversation like that's not reality
like we can't have a discussion about
reality in that way right like there's
mostly think guys will find any reason
to pay you compliments and they'll find
the same thing to talk about when it's
Hey listen how do I get this girl's
attention oh you have a match it you
know
full of people shooting their shot so
I'm sure yeah I mean but I don't think
that's because of your degrees mean look
at your Instagram
that know me personally I would say
right but I think what we're trying to
get at is that I think that the reason
that your folder is as long and
full as it is it's not because you are
on your Instagram talking about you know
quadratic equations and postings
it's because of the way that it's
because of the way that you look and the
things that you're posting and I think
what we're saying this is what a lot of
women miss all of that is okay
all that's okay right like
we're not here I think what a lot of
guys will do when they try to say like
oh you're so smart and I love that you
make all this money and you have all
these degrees like I think a lot of that
is disingenuous
most guys just want a woman that is down
for the cause she's Pleasant she's fun
to be around
let's be honest I mean if if if degrees
were that important then women would use
their social media and Instagram feeds
showcasing pictures of the degrees and
the type of kind of mahogany they put
them into the lighting but that doesn't
get likes that won't get you your DMs
you know with proposals right
um it's like
to you know to argue that women are
Beauty objects and success objects to me
like you can't really be both
right men are success objects and women
are Beauty objects and it's kind of
always been that way and I think that
we're we're seeing
a cultural move where Society is trying
to be convinced that women can both be
beautiful and successful and there are
women that pull it off
but they also lack in other areas in
life where maybe they have their beauty
which Fades by the way over time and
maybe they have their success but they
never end up with a family or they never
end up with a guy in their life that you
know is a compliment that they can do
things with that she can look up to that
can protect her if [__] hits a fan
right so
I wonder why there's a
a strong pull to be both like I wouldn't
want to be a beauty object and a success
object if I was a woman
but I guess I'm not a woman so that's
difficult for me to
comprehend I don't know well and I I did
want to add on to sort of the going back
to like the achievements and being proud
of achievements just as some women you
know climbing the corporate ladder
um you know getting degrees and things
like that those are their achievements
um for so many other women their
achievements are their children and
being able to raise their own family
that you know raise contributing members
of society that are you know going to be
their legacy that lives on
um and that I think a lot of women find
that to be a lot more of a fulfilling
route than at the end of the day you
said being a slave to you know a large
corporation where you're just climbing
on making someone else more money you're
making great money and accomplishing a
lot for yourself but you're making
somebody else even more money and then
when you die like what do you have
what do you have left like what did you
leave with the world I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out